let's start this evening with the
breaking news that thousands of
ambulance staff paramedics and 999 call
handlers have voted in favor of strikes
Before Christmas in the past hour the
union Unison has said that its members
in the Northeast Northwest and Southwest
and Yorkshire and London have voted to
walk out if an NHS pay increase is not
agreed with the union now in a statement
Union Unison has said this patients will
always come first and emergency cover
will be available during any strike but
unless NHS pay and Staffing get fixed
services and Care will continue to
decline the public knows Health Services
won't improve without huge increases in
Staffing and wants the government to pay
up to save the NHS it's high time that
ministers stopped using the pay review
bodies cover for their inaction the
statement continues that Jeremy Hunt
Rishi sunak and Steve he must roll up
their sleeves and start talking to
unions about how better wedges for staff
can help start to turn the NHS around
while our cheap political correspondent
John Craig is here to tell us more about
this breaking news so potentially
another headache for the government in
the run-up to Christmas this is a major
escalation potentially of strikes in the
National Health Service because last
week the Royal College of Nursing
announced two strike dates Thursday the
15th and Tuesday the 20th of December
what is significant about this
announcement from Unison tonight there
are no strike dates mentioned they are
talking about date strikes Before
Christmas likely so it's possible they
may not go ahead because the union does
say that its health committee is
analyzing the results of the strike
ballot and will decide what happens next
and there's a clue here in the statement
where it talks about the vote was below
the 50 000 threshold in many trusts
suggests that the strike vote may not
have been overwhelming now you've
mentioned the regions where there are
going to be strikes the people involved
according to the union will be ambulance
workers across England
um 999 call handlers ambulance
technicians paramedics and their
colleagues working for for ambulance
services so we're talking about the
Emergency Services really on top of the
uh the nurses the nurses Striker
announced last week was really
threatening outpatients appointments and
operations in hospitals mainly this is
the emergency Cruise no date fixed yet
you might think they might coincide with
those dates of the 15th and 20th of
December but the the Unicorn big public
sector Union no strike dates yet call as
you've said for more talks Steve Barkley
has met the Royal College of Nursing on
the 10th and 15th of November he's been
criticized for not having more meetings
with the health unions just tell us
about how the pay is decided the Unison
referring then to these pay review
bodies at arm's length from the
government yes whenever you hear a
minister uh quizzed about the uh about
the pay dispute they say oh well we've
we've accepted the recommendations of
the pay review body Mr Barkley the
health secretary and indeed Mark Harper
the transport secretary who has met the
rmt have said that what the unions are
demanding is is unaffordable but
inflation is creeping up uh to 11 or 12
11 now that and the the RCN in
particular is asking for five percent
above the inflation rate so as long as
the government says the rates are
unaffordable it looks as though there's
complete deadlock here the one piece of
good news is that the the Unison have
held back from announcing the dates and
they've said in their statement likely
to strike so it's not definitely they're
going ahead memory hope that okay John
thank you you very much indeed John
Craig our chief political correspondent
there and by the way if you'd like to
find out more about how you might be
affected by any NHS winter action you
can scan the QR code on the screen there
for a full list of NHS employers
affected by the walkout you find all the
details as well on the Sky News app and
on the Sky News website